times for me it was emotional and i was
a bit somber
and now i'm getting a bit emotional so
yeah it was um
part of the history i was i'm part of
the history so it's nice to be there
party
slow
march
the queen's company first battalion
grenadier guards carried the queen from
the gun carriage to westminster hall
their commander in chief
also a military wife mother and
grandmother and the first female royal
to join the armed services
here princess catherine and the duchess
of sussex joined their husbands the
archbishop of canterbury read the
opening prayer
oh god
the maker and redeemer of all mankind
grant us
with thy servant queen elizabeth king
charles faced the coffin in this last
moment with his mother until the funeral
on monday
a double tap from the officer of the
watch signaled the start of the first
vigil kept by four officers from the
household cavalry
while outside the queue began to stretch
down the thames across it and back on
itself the public in waiting
and they will wait and wait for hours on
end for this last chance to spend just a
moment with their queen
and say goodbye
each in their own way
jason farrell sky news
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can watch the
queens lying in state in full on the sky
news website and mobile apps
now to help you plan the department for
digital culture media and sport have
released a live stream showing the
length of the queue as you can see it's
currently 2.4 miles long that's around 4
kilometers
well
king charles has now left london
following today's procession
earlier this afternoon he was filmed
returning to highgrove his home in
gloucestershire
it's not yet clear how long he will
remain there before returning to the
capitol
our royal correspondent laura bundock is
with me as is patrick harrison the
king's former press secretary
one of the surprises of the last couple
of days has i guess been the wash of
emotion that seems
across the nation about the queen
herself
um but the second big surprise i think
has been perhaps
the um
warmth towards the new king as far as we
can make out has that surprised you
laura
well we meet the crowds so in northern
ireland yesterday for example it was a
it was an effort to get there there was
a ring of steel around hillsborough
castle people had to park their car up
miles away they had to drive be driven
in buses airport style sort of security
to get there but everyone i spoke to
said nothing of course we want to come
here we want to come here we want to
say farewell to the queen say thank you
and pay our condolences to the king but
we want to welcome him as well and there
was a
probable energy i think in the crowd as
well i think it's been noticed here as
well that on the one hand you have the
grieving of a monarch but at the other
hand you have the welcoming of a new one
and so there's this jewel thing going on
here where the crowds that you know it's
a somber it is a it is a somber moment
in the crowd but at the same time i
think certainly for people coming here
coming to london or we've seen in
edinburgh and and in northern ireland so
far
a sense that they they want to show
their support and we've seen that with
his family as well with all the messages
and support they they've been indeed
in fact um
patrick i noticed
the
phrase god save the king actually
emerged for the first time i heard it
for the first time when you were in
northern ireland and i see it's been
picked up here um i don't think people
would quite have imagined that this was
the reception that charles was going to
get if you go back 10 or 15 years has
that struck you well
what struck me is that people are
responding to this event in multiple
ways and i think that we all see that
this is a family grieving and just as we
are in some way mourning the queen
different levels so we also recognize
that this is a family who are saying
goodbye to a much
loved member of their family the head of
their family but i think there's also
some reflection that we've witnessed in
the extraordinary work that the royal
family do the queen and her commitment
of duty but also all the other members
of the royal family uh princess royal
for example the hardest working member
of the royal family each year does more
engagements than everybody else and i
think people are reflecting on the fact
that the king has already spent 50 years
of his life in public service so i think
it's on multiple levels that people are
showing their support for the royal
family and for the institution of
monarchy well
one of the interesting things is that
people that we can see that now because
of course we've got water wall coverage
of what's going on in the streets and so
on um would it be fair to say that the
um the planning now for
these days
has for the first time i think of in
these kind of stage occasions really um
anticipated if you like the emergence of
natural rituals the flowers uh the quiet
applause which i think came as a
surprise to people um and actually if
you're thinking about natural rituals
there's now the cue i mean that is the
most british ritual you could imagine
we love it yeah if you had to have a
symbol for for britishness that's it but
as the planning sort of take into
account this sort of change sentiment
the desire of the public to be part of
it rather than
behind
i was involved with the london bridge as
we called it planning the planning for
all these 10 days up to the funeral
from the year 2000 to the year 2014.
well a lot changed in that time
obviously we had the advent of smart
technology so as we were looking at
these plans we realized that people
would be able to follow information on
their tablets on their phones um and we
also looked at how we could engage the
public in in new ways so um matching
make making sure we were matching the
ceremony and the traditional with
perhaps more modern expectations of
of of the public's involvement uh one
example might be the accession council
we had a debate about whether or not we
should televise the accession council
wasn't televised back in 1952 i believe
very strongly that it should be
televised this time this time round and
i was thrilled that it was because i
think in this day and age you need to
show and explain
the ritual and understand what's going
on and we saw there the crown as the
sort of binding glue if you like of the
constitutional monarchy and you saw all
those other politicians
from opposing size and you saw members
of the clergy and all others there and
the crown as that unifying force uh uh
over the top if you like there in the
accession council i thought was very
powerful to be able to see that just a
matter of interest i don't want you
giving it give away any state secrets
when was the decision made that the
accession council should be televised
that would have been made right now
because just in the in the last week or
so because um these plans are always
ultimate for the ultimate sanction at
the time so you create all these plans
they're they're ready to go but of
course you know um you also have to make
the final decision as you move through
i think what's interesting though is
while you have the traditional the
ceremonial
even televised it felt a little
inaccessible could we name all the
people all the roles all the titles even
the trumpeters but at the same time
stick in waiting but that's why i think
we saw on that very same day incredible
walkabouts as well because i think as
king charles knows we've got that side
of the job yeah and it's it's grand
the uniforms all of that um and people
who like it will engage a bit we'll
always engage in it but at the same time
he wants to see people he wants to meet
people which is why we've had this
really quick whiz around the nation so
it's going to end in wales on friday
this week
that's why i think it's a 24-hour
operation to get as many people as
possible through westminster hall at the
moment because he knows how much this
moment means to people and as a new
monarch he wants to make sure that he
brings the people with him on this
journey and he needs their support along
the way and that was his style also when
he was prince of wales i remember when
working with him he hated driving past
crowds and we'd quite often get the call
we're going to stop short as it was
called which is stopping the car short
of the destination so that he'd get out
and meet members of the club you just
decide on the moment i'm going to stop i
think we'd like to start we'd like i
need to meet the crowd because they've
come out you can't you don't always know
whether you're going to get a crowd or
not but if there is a crowd there um he
always felt that if he could if there
was time uh then then he'd like to meet
them sometimes you'd have a ceremonial
reason why you had to carry on and
because it was starting time of a church
service or something like that but if he
could meet the crowd then he would i can
imagine what would be going through the
protection officer's mind well let's
let's return to the security point in a
moment
now as you watch the pictures of the
public walking past the queen's coffin
which we'll see in a moment
you would be hard-pressed to find a
better cross-section of british society
people of every age every background
represented each with their own reason
for for putting aside hours of their own
time to come to westminster but with the
same person as their inspiration
sky's nick martin has been talking to
some of those queueing for the queen
in the long queues they watch the
television coverage of this historic
event
they're all part of history now
and at the very front of this line are
three ladies who forged a friendship
vanessa annie and grace spent four days
sleeping here and they'll be the first
to see the queen lie in state
i don't know what i'm going to be
expecting in there when you walk in
we'll be just saying prayers in my heart
for her peaceful rest and
thank mom for the great service that
she's done for
70 years in rain
nonstop if i didn't get the chance
to be in the first i would have still
come to
queue up anyway well i just think it's
we like the ceremonial aspect of it the
guards gleaming buttons the polish
you know the regimentation when the
guards come by i've just
been enthralled by it and thrilled by it
since i was four if i were to be on the
back maybe i feel i'll feel
tired to go home but because i'm i'm
just there here in the front of the cube
i feel so
it gave me the courage the determination
it is a huge effort directing so many
people into one place
eight-year-old louis jenkinson from
oxford told me he's a big fan of the
queen she was a very funny woman
i liked the pudding paddington bear
[ __ ] yeah that was cool wasn't it yeah
it was pretty funny yeah well thanks for
talking to me louis well this is the
longest conversation i've had with a
reporter is it yeah i do go on a bit
and this is what they were waiting for
to see with their own eyes
to be in the same room
to have their moment with their queen
we're waiting you're queuing up for this
moment but the moment you see the coffin
it
it is a
it hits you and
i don't think you're ever really ready
for that
we all came out my daughter my
granddaughter and i came out you know
quite emotional really to give her our
respect for everything that she's done
70 years of service
you won't find a better queen will you
there are now thousands of people
queueing to see the queen lie in state
and this line goes on for miles young
old some from nearby others have
traveled from far afield
but they are all part
of a remarkable people's pilgrimage
they are unforgettable images of a
nation mourning nick martin sky news
westminster
well there are lots of people still on
that pilgrimage sky's ashna horinaga is
at westminster bridge with the people
trying to catch up with those who've
already been to pay their respects to
the queen
well people are still filtering through
after having been inside westminster
hall they're coming up uh this route
here and there are people who have just
been inside that building there where
they have been inside to see and walk
around her majesty's coffin and two
people who have done just that too i'd
like to introduce you to maurice and
gina who are over here these are some
thousands of people now we are talking
about who've queued up for hours maurice
and gina thank you so much for chatting
to us tell us what it was like being in
the inside there amazing
really amazing
i mean we we queued and
we just thought it was the best day to
come
and pay our respects and so yeah we're
glad we did
can you talk to us about what it felt
like to be inside there because everyone
we've spoken to says it's so still it's
so somber and quiet how did you feel
i wouldn't say somber yes it was quiet
but i suppose it just goes with the um
you know with everything that's
happening
and the loss
she was a great loss
traveled here from leicestershire why
did you want to make this journey today
pay our respects i think
to show our appreciation
yeah what did you
say what did you think about in your
head i know you couldn't speak out loud
but were you thinking about anything in
particular we prayed for her yeah
why is that
well she was she was very strong with
her faith
and
we did
yeah
you know pleased that you've done it
relieved you've done it or at peace i
suppose yeah very happy that we did make
this journey she dragged me
but it wasn't yeah it was worth it
and how long were you queueing for
finally uh i think since 2 30 2 30. not
bad at all it's showing that the line is
moving fairly quickly they were very
organized thank you both so much and
then get back to that's just
all right
so many people are making that journey
and they are trickling through trevor
every so often you've got a wave of
people and they've all come from seeing
her majesty inside walked around that
coffin and paid their own respects this
line will continue to move now over the
next four days this will be going
throughout the night and people i guess
feeling that sense of grief um those
particular ladies said that they felt
happy and pleased they were finally able
to be there interestingly she's saying
that she didn't feel like it was a
somber mood
but many people here we have seen crying
tears down their faces it really is a
sense of mixed emotions but definitely
a different
sense and feeling here in the capital
today compared to the past few days
where people have been queuing up and
perhaps there was more celebratory
atmosphere today it feels a little bit
more still
thank you arshner and um i think that
point about the mixture of moods is
really important we'll return to that
with uh
laura and patrick in a moment but people
from all over the country and further
afield are expected to come to london in
the next few days each will have their
own personal reasons why the queen was
so important to them
tom parmenter has been to cheshire and
north wales to meet some of those
preparing to make the trip down to
london set on paying their respects
from all corners of this kingdom they
are coming with purpose
and provisions
chicken sandwiches we are choosing a new
crisp
mountain chocolate cookies
a little munch in the queue from
dominique's kitchen in witness
to paula's back garden in prestatin yeah
so we had lots of buntin everywhere um
we had blooms up it was only june when
the platinum jubilee party here was in
full swing the queen made her appearance
she was just here
in full vision and she had two little
corgis with her
now paula and her daughter
just want to go to london
and say thank you
she wasn't with me at the time when i
was in the mall in 2002 she was actually
an assignment to me not knowing i was
loving a boy or a girl at the time
so to take her with me 20 years later
for a different occasion for a more
somber occasion but
for a royal occasion
it's your family and it's their family
yeah
they'll be up early the coach pickups
along this stretch of the north wales
coastline start at 2 15 a.m
but geraint is all set it is the
headline of of this century i would have
thought it's you know
you don't
you're not involved in this every day
and
some way shape or form everybody is
involved
on t side ben has just sorted his train
it's a trip he's making on behalf of his
mum
my mother was a massive supporter of the
queen she's no longer with us and i feel
that it's an opportunity to make her
part of this moment as well you could
say that part of the glue of society has
come a little bit unstuck
um and it's brought the country together
um to reassess where we go from here
back in witness there's another train to
catch i think it's truly what makes us
british monarchy yeah
you seem quite cued up by it today yeah
yeah yeah totally yeah
yeah uh
i mean i would i would have got it any
way i could have
all this has actually moved people and
for however long it lasts right now this
country feels like a more united kingdom
and that
is quite a legacy
i am feeling
i am so glad we're here so we found the
end
they see it as their duty
to take a place
in their nation's story
tom parmenter sky news
laura and patrick are still with me
patrick
we're hearing a lot about the sort of
stoicism people in the cube but one
thing that's emerging
rather clearly is a very
unusual mix of if you like sadness and
celebration which
normally don't sit together very well
but
seem to be going in parallel i think as
laura was saying uh earlier on on this
occasion
is
it's the unique nature of this event
isn't it and it it starts at the very
moment that of course
the queen sadly passes away and long
live the king suddenly you have a new
king so right from the start you have a
period of mourning a much-loved monarch
who has been our guiding light for
generations and you also get this new
era
this the start of a new reign and so
right from that big from the very start
and uh
and i think that uh what's been
interesting is that those two parallel
emotions have carried on throughout the
days what are we now so seven days in um
and through all the ceremony and the
pageantry on one side and the personal
acts of remembrance that we've seen both
from members of royal family but also
from from the public those two uh
parallel emotions are still running
in parallel tonight
it's it's a it's an unusual thing i mean
we wouldn't have expected to see these
two things um uh running together
given the somberness of the you know of
what has happened but there's still a
sort of rather
i won't i won't say upbeat
but very positive mood oh i think i
think you can say upbeat actually i do
feel in the crowds
um the inevitable sorrow that people who
are coming here may feel is is
absolutely running in tandem with an
expectation and a positive one certainly
from people who are coming to the
palaces to
to meet the new king
that this is this is a a continuum he's
not shape-shifting from prince of wales
to king it just happened straight away
so this is his role um and they're
expecting him to fulfill it and it was
interesting in northern ireland
yesterday speaking to certainly older
people who'd gathered there saying well
look he's had the absolute best tutor
you could possibly expect so we've loved
seeing the queen as head of state we now
know it is her son the king who takes
over and you know he he's had a long
time training for this but the absolute
best teacher possible so
there is a hope suddenly there that he
will carry on and let's remember the
northern ireland music was the most
sensitive one of all the tours of the
nation so it was it was a tricky day you
know
publicly and politically with the
meetings that were going on and it's
interesting even at highgrove this
evening we're hearing of all the calls
so after this enormous procession this
big moment of leading the national grief
leading his family's grief then having
to have calls with governor general from
australia you know heads of state really
big calls taking place
whilst trying to have a bit of downtime
at highgrove where it is his home where
it is a private place and perhaps he is
trying to also take this private moment
for grief as well but i think there's
also a bit of national pride here as
well i think we're proud of our
institution we're proud of the
ceremonies that we put on the procession
today is is something that people are
very proud of that that we do i think
we'll be very very proud as a nation
that the eyes of the world will be on us
on monday when that funeral takes place
and i think we are also
very proud of the fact that we have a
king who cares passionately about some
of the subjects that affect our lives
such as the environment a king who in
1976 with his naval pension set up the
prince's trust which has helped over a
million young people yes in fact
somebody said to me earlier on today in
in the very british way that we do this
we do this better than anybody else and
i have to confess i i watched for the
whole of the 38 minutes
that it took them to come from here to
westminster hall to see if anybody
missed a step and what was striking
not a single person mis misa step that's
the pageantry and that's the organized
thing but i'm very interested in
i said earlier on that these natural
rituals seem to be evolving we get the
flowers now at these kinds of events um
and we've seen this as i say these
ripples of applause as the king and his
siblings pass which seems to me to be um
a new thing and i heard um one of our uh
one of our colleagues talking to people
in the queue today
about what you should do when you come
to the catapult should you bow should
you curtsy and so it's really
again watching it everybody seems to
have just without being told what to do
to have found a natural way
of doing things gracefully i think it's
in you look at the people who are filing
past now live in westminster hall you
can see
there'll be a little
mexican wave of nodding i think maybe
that's a group who were with each other
in the queue other people will just
stand and pause
but given the amount of time they've
been queueing you get this very brief
moment in this enormous room i mean the
size of it is quite something coming
down those two it sort of hits you
really there's a blaze of red in the
middle surrounded by the gray stone and
it is interesting i think they've cued
with something they wanted to do but the
moment
you can see it sort of there's a
gentleman there but you can see it
almost on the face the the awe yeah and
kind of here i am
this is it yeah and then the pause and
then that very
calm peaceful private moment
very brief but very personal and the
silence has been the silence at various
moments has been striking but also very
expressive
absolutely and i think you know with all
the meticulous planning that underpins
this there's also here we're seeing the
freedom to allow people to express their
respects in whichever way they feel most
comfortable whether it's a a knot of the
head or just a slow pause in front or we
saw earlier a couple of gentlemen take
their hats off we've seen different
different forms of expression um that
the people that maybe is going to hear
the story of being there for the rest of
his life
isn't that the sweetest thing maybe he's
carried him because you can't take any
push chairs in there and um yes gosh
that baby she's
she's been carrying him for hours i
would think yeah yeah ex
amazing um
the the king tonight patrick will as uh
laura has been saying
be on to some very important people
yes he's made a lot of phone calls we
understand to today um to various heads
of state including uh president biden
and high commissioners of the realms of
course many of these people he will know
this is a man who has himself been in
public life for over 50 years and will
know many of these people if not all of
them personally and he'll have visited
many if not all of their their countries
but also in highgrove tonight which is
his
own home
he'll also have a time to to reflect
he's now been in the public eye for
seven days um at a time of his own
personal grieving and so i hope at least
he'll have a little bit of time tonight
just to
pause and reflect as well okay well
who knows he might be watching the telly
now if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest episode of the sky news daily
podcast with leo baleto which takes a
look at today's events in full including
a conversation with the archbishop of
canterbury justin welby you can
subscribe to the daily for free wherever
you get your podcasts
after the profession from buckingham
palace to westminster hall earlier today
let's look at what's in store over the
coming days
the queen's lying in state began just
over four hours ago
she'll remain there until the morning of
the funeral on monday
on friday the kingdom queen consort will
travel to cardiff where they'll attend
the prayer service and meet the welsh
first minister
on sunday evening the night before the
funeral king charles will host a
reception for foreign dignitaries who
will attend
a minutes of silence will also be held
across the uk at 8pm to honour the queen
then on the morning of the 19th of
september the lying in state ends and
the queen's coffin will be taken in
procession to westminster abbey for her
state funeral
well there's nothing that british people
love more than a cube but one might have
thought that the winding mass of people
waiting to pay their respects to the
queen might be enough to give even the
most determined visitor pause for
thought
no not so it seems skies becky johnson
has spent the day with people waiting
patiently at the back of the queue
are you looking for the back of the gear
yeah yeah
in true british tradition people came
prepared to queue
even knowing they'd be here for hours
didn't stop people joining in their
thousands the end of the queue moving
back and back
by 11am it had reached the london eye
joining the line was bryony with her
three months old
little indiana blissfully unaware of the
weight that
back
lay
cute as well um i haven't told any of
your family or friends because they all
think i'm insane um bringing my child
but i forget it's a once in a lifetime
opportunity
and we'll never have another queen again
well we've been talking you're not the
back of the queue anymore
that's very exciting she's an incredible
woman she'll be
oh god i'm not even from here but
i just feel like she's had a profound
impact on all of us and
it's part of history
by lunchtime kofi was keeping count how
many have we got so far
a sign was found for him to wear to
signal the back of the queue people want
to come and see the queen to show their
last respect to their queen that's why
they are coming up with their numbers
at 2 p.m the latest to join were at the
oxo tower this is the end yes you've got
there you've got there
four-year-old effie settling in for a
long wait with her mum
fa is queen and princess mad she loves
all the queen's outfits and how colorful
her hats are
and she's been asking a lot to come and
help bury the queen she's bored of
crying all day in school she hasn't took
it off
because she's
respecting the queen under individuality
in the afternoon sunshine they kept
coming
as people wait the back of the queue
never stands still every second brings
new arrivals
by 5 pm the queue stretched almost back
to hms belfast but as the first mourners
went in to see the queen the line moved
forwards bringing those towards the back
a little closer
for the sacrifice and all the work she
did even the day before she left us she
ushered in a new prime minister
that dedication
it's priceless so
a few minutes a few hours it's worth it
so many are prepared to wait over the
coming days many thousands more will
join the back of the queue
becky johnson sky news central london
president biden spoke to king charles
today to offer his condolences on the
death of the queen
and express his wish to continue a close
relationship with the king
it was another day of busy diplomacy for
the monarch who also spoke to the
president of ireland
and france
let's talk about that and some of the
wider issues now in the build-up to the
funeral on monday with lord daruc the
former uk ambassador to the united
states he was also the uk's national
security adviser lord derek of course
we have to remember that president biden
as well as being the leader of the
the chief executive of the united states
is also their head of state so
presumably this conversation was head of
state to head of state it was
as you say he's both head of the
administration and head of state
unlike king charles who is just a
constitutional monarch so he has a
slightly wider remit than uh than king
charles does so what would that
conversation
have been about i mean what what what do
i i don't know what does sovereign and
head of states talk to each other about
they know each other already trevor i
mean the most recent time they met i
think was at that uh that big climate
change conference uh a year or so ago in
glasgow
and i think they're both quite strong on
green issues so the any policy would
have been on on on the importance of the
environment but i think it was primarily
the president expressing his condolences
for the death of her majesty
and uh saying to taking charles his best
wishes for his
his future role and looking forward to
seeing him at the uh the state funeral
on monday
and um we understand he's also spoken to
mr macron and uh i wonder if there might
have been a mild
awkwardness about the degree of
friendship between us and
and france right now i understand why
you would ask i kind of doubt it and i
have to say i thought president macron's
message
um after the death of uh of the queen
was extraordinarily generous and
beautifully worded so
um i think actually it
spoke of a genuine admiration on
president macron's past for her majesty
and i think that he and uh he and king
charles will get on just fine
laura there's um i mean there's a lot of
diplomacy going on and we're going to
see
um all of
the foreign dignitaries i think 30 heads
of state or something like that coming
into town on sunday that is going to be
a jamboree a big reception yeah and a
big moment really because this is
first time as king obviously
i think most of the people there if not
all of them will have already met and
will have a relationship with with the
king but this is his first moment isn't
it as monarch and we've seen lots of
these political meetings taking place um
from the political parties um here in
westminster then also in scotland in
northern ireland as well where the
political situation became although full
well is particularly fragile at the
moment and he will know and appreciate
the role his mother had um
in a very important role over the years
and a role he's tried to replicate with
various handshakes along the way but
certainly these diplomatic meetings are
very much part of the job aren't they a
a significant moment for him now taking
on that mantle
as monarch as opposed to the prince of
wales in the past
lord you both made the point that he
knows all of these people and in fact
you
saw the pictures of him with the
head the ambassadors and high
commissioners from the realms it's clear
he
spent a lot of time with these people
of course he's now a different
entity i won't say a person he's a
different entity
when he meets these new these
heterostates over the uh this weekend um
he's going to be meeting them in a
completely new guys what what signal
should we look for that tell us that
actually
this is a new charles because
he said in all these speeches now
i am going to be
not the person you knew before
i am going to be
more like my mother
in that what should we look for to see
the difference he's been preparing for
this role literally for decades as laura
says
he is much traveled and he will know
many of the heads of state and heads of
government who are attending
i thought that that television address
that he did uh the day after after his
mother's death was announced was
absolutely pitch perfect and there was
important signals there about how he was
going to conduct
uh his uh
his
uh his time as uh as king
and i think you will see him
um steering clear of anything in public
that is remotely controversial i mean he
was famous for his uh standing up for
environmental issues i think you you
shouldn't hear any of that i think it'll
be very correct
and uh
and uh i think he will he will
accomplish the task uh admirably because
he is so well prepared for it and from
the same he knows exactly how he's going
to do it yes
i i do think that we ought not to um
ignore the fact that his mother would
have found ways of sending signals the
famous moment where at cop26
apparently unaware that there were any
microphones uh near her i think that's
unlikely
she said they talk but they don't do
which is a pretty big
pretty big signal i think he will be
very cautious at least initially i'd be
surprised if we saw any of that uh
trevor but you know we know him to be a
man of strong views on some issues so
you'll find ways of getting across in
private even if he is very very cautious
in public
um one of the big things you were
national security adviser one of the big
things that we're going to have to
confront frankly is
keeping all of these
dignitaries safe and by the way
protecting
the crowds from any potential
um any potential danger
how big an operation is this going to
have to be it may just be the biggest in
in history at least in recent history um
i can't imagine
uh just how huge a task it is when you
have to basically protect 70 odd
dignitaries
every minute they are here
and uh that means when they're in the
hotels or in their residences when
they're on the way to the uh to the
events when they're in the in in the
service we're in the reception at
buckingham palace on sunday night and
then another reception i think after the
funeral so it's a huge task spreading
over two or three days so i'm not
surprised that basically the entire
police force in the country seems to be
pulled into it massive laura we we heard
um that there's quite a lot of special
arrangements being made
uh the president of the united states
has been allowed to bring his own car i
imagine that this thing they call the
beast uh but uh everybody else is going
to be on the bus is that right it's
going to be a bus we've seen we've seen
busloads coming in before in fact we've
seen busloads of royals as well the
gills all uh the service there or the
lunch there there was a bus bringing in
you know it was amazing actually seeing
them all filing off the bus basically
royal after oil after royal because
there is there is a problem you've got a
lot of people to get in there and you
know you can't clog up the roads with
lots and lots of cars and people getting
out of lots of cars so it will be buses
of dignitaries but not president but i
don't know i mean it's worth adding here
that the
protocol won't be perfect it can't be
perfect with this number of
distinguished guests but first and
foremost
this is a
commemoration
of and celebration of an extraordinary
woman and an extraordinary life so you
would expect heads of government
and heads of state just for this this
couple of days to say well
that's what i'm here for and you know
the protocol isn't that important when
it's this sort of event there'll be a
lot going on um aside from the uh the
royal obsequies that we will see
this will be probably the biggest
gathering of these kinds of people for
some time so presumably there'll be a
lot of bilaterals going on they will be
meeting face-to-face to talk about
there are other things going on in the
world of course ukraine and so on how
much of this is an opportunity for them
some of the leaders to meet each other
it's unquestionably a major opportunity
as you say one of the biggest diplomatic
gatherings in recent history
and
people will not want to say in public
this has been an opportunity for me to
do these six seven ten bilaterals
because that will be a touch
disrespectful to
the centerpiece of these two or three
days but with that gathering of heads of
government and heads of state around
they will talk to one another and there
will be some set-piece bilaterals and an
awful lot of mingling in the margins
and quite a lot of business might be
done
okay
let's
for the moment let's return i think
we're going to return to the
uh procession uh no we're not we're
going to the queues because that is the
that that is the big story of the day i
think uh our matthew thompson is in
southeast london where people are
beginning
what could be a very
long
hard wait
matthew
i know you've been out there
are you still at the back
look anyone who thought that as the
light went and as the colder air set in
the queue would start to dissipate well
they would have been very wrong you can
just see behind me that the queue is as
alive as ever it's perhaps slightly
shorter than it was an hour or so ago i
think at its maximum the queue was
pushing three miles plus long it was way
back at london bridge so it's short
shortened slightly it's still around
saint paul's night just by black friar's
bridge but still two and a half miles
away from westminster so there's no sign
of this queue slowing down anytime soon
but what would possess someone at this
time of night to come and join a cue
that might keep them here right through
the evening well i've got some people
who are going to help us answer that
question what is it that possesses you
to join the queue whatever what time is
it nearly 10 o'clock yeah we've come to
see you you can't see me
so we've inspired we've inspired you to
come is that the deal that's right
and the queen presumably as well well it
was your last call when you said you
know the queue is moving at a fast pace
i just got back from work
he just said to me look there's an
opportunity that we might be able to get
to see the queen
um you know
she
has been our queen history so it's
history in the making so
you know we thought well yeah and this
is your chance to be a part of it
yeah
she's been the longest reigning monarch
so
how long would you have you got a sort
of cut off in mind like if you were
still here at two o'clock in the morning
would you go home or are you prepared to
sit it out right the way
get something to eat or drink
exactly i've got 11 to 18 year olds to
teach tomorrow well good luck with that
thank you guys thank you ever so much
thank you so as you can see the queue is
moving quite quickly it's been pretty
much like that we've been here
throughout the day since about
two o'clock this afternoon the queue has
been moving like this for nearly five
hours now and shows absolutely no signs
of slowing so if you are intending on
coming out late to maybe catch a
shortened queue you might be
disappointed but the one piece of advice
i would give you is wrap up warm plan
some food and drinks and also as lots of
the restaurants things close you might
want to think a little bit about where
you can have your bathroom breaks as
well
there is matthew bond matthew thompson
with some great domestic advice for
anybody who wants to come out to join
that two and a half mile cue and laura
bundock is with me once again um
matthew put it in his inimitable way
what would possess you to get out there
i think when you speak to people and
you've been hearing from them before
they go in and before they come out
and the thing i find
interesting is that
this didn't happen before in previous
flying in states we all have mobile
phones we all have televisions there is
news on everywhere
you can access these pictures wherever
you are basically i think most people
can at least switch on a tv and watch
them and yet when you hear from people
in the crowds it's not enough
they want to be there they want to they
want to do it in person
and i think that's what i find so
interesting that the cues no matter how
long they are i mean lots of people have
said she served 70 years we can do 24
hours in a queue and i think in the rain
that especially hit home to many of us
but i think there is that that absolute
connection there because
she was a monarch who wanted to be out
there to be seen with people i think in
return
people are wanting to do the same to her
which is why i think
you are seeing these really long queues
with absolute steely determination
people joining them uh goodness knows
what time of night with no idea when
they might get to the front of the queue
because they want that moment and it's a
very very brief moment as they enter
westminster hall
very very few seconds is over
but those seconds mean everything and
that is their way i think you can see
people lining up now and they will be
doing this all the way through the night
there is no break in this right up until
the early hours of monday morning it
will be a non-stop
lying in state people want to be there
they want that moment to pause to
reflect and in their own personal way to
say thank you it's it's it's a very
telling thing this this
physical bond isn't it because
uh it's easy to forget that actually
this
late queen
was the monarch who
reintroduced i think is the right word
the walk about the
physical
uh proximity to people you have to go
back pretty much medieval times to
find kings and queens who would be out
there their people you know when queen
elizabeth uh
would walk actually walk through the
streets after that very unusual i mean
it is a very striking thing now that
this
direct relationship at a time when we've
got all the other media
uh
other channels and so on this direct
relationship has become important again
yeah and
when i was in northern ireland yesterday
everyone was filming so you can barely
see what's going on because there's so
many people holding cameras up they want
to record that moment and they also want
to be there as well and it is is
remarkable and i i'm still really struck
watching the people filing past the
coffin here everyone having that small
brief moment it is incredible a real
moment of history
laura thank you very much
and now we'll return to the procession
of the queen's coffin from buckingham
palace to westminster hall where it now
lies in state for four days
dermot murnahan explains how the events
unfolded
[Music]
the queen's coffin was taken from its
position inside buckingham palace and
placed on a gun carriage at the grand
entrance
it left in procession followed by
members of the royal family led by the
queen's four children including the king
to the sound of minute guns the
procession carried the queen along the
mall for the last time
before turning right onto horse guards
parade
with big ben tolling every minute the
procession crossed the great ceremonial
parade ground
sight of trooping the color on the
queen's official birthday each year
then turning onto white hall it traveled
past some of the great offices of
government
downing street and the cenotaph which
commemorates the nation's war dead
entering parliament square the
procession turned into new palace yard
in front of the houses of parliament
and then into westminster hall where the
queen's coffin is now lying in state for
the days before her funeral
the procession made its way into the
oldest part of the palace of westminster
led by heralds and then the most senior
figures in parliament the palace and the
church of england
the coffin draped with the royal
standard was placed on a raised platform
the catafalc
in the middle of westminster hall
the king queen consort and other members
of the royal family behind
after a short service led by the
archbishop of canterbury the procession
party left and members of the yeoman of
the guard and the household division
took up positions around the coffin
forming a vigil that will guard the
queen
as she lies in state until her funeral
so
one more solemn and emotional day here
in london with the queen now lying in
state at the palace of
westminster the king his siblings and
his sons walked behind her coughing
along the mall across
horse guards parade and down to
whitehall to deliver her majesty to the
nation
ahead of monday's state funeral
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
inwards
[Music]
presence
[Music]
oh
[Music]